Please welcome Britt Lower!
(audience applauds)
Hi.
I'm so excited that you're here.
Adam Scott, your leading man, was just here,
and we were talking about the show.
I've been watching it.
It's insane, it is very different.
And I love that.
And I guess everybody else does too.
That's what I'm hearing.
I mean, it's an office thriller with an odd sense of humor.
Okay, so is it true that you and your mom
did face painting together?
It's true, yeah.
And I actually, when I lived here in New York,
just starting out as an actor,
that's how I paid for my groceries.
So I escaped being a starving artist
by painting kids' faces.
Wow, that's so cool.
Okay, something else we have in common
that I'm really excited to ask you about is RVing.
When I was 19, I discovered life on the road.
But it's the most sort of liberating,
I think it's the ultimate form of freedom.
Why do you like it?
Well, I think anytime I'm experiencing loss
or heartbreak or need to heal, I like to get on the road,
because it's this meditation of watching the miles go by.
The other thing that I like to do with it
is I go and I find a small tenting circus
and I watch the circus,
and it's this sense of awe and wonderment.
I mean, I just like to feel like I'm a kid again
and sit in the audience.
Is it true that you also hopped in your RV, like you said,
if you're having heartbreak or loss,
like this is a breakup sort of cure-all for you.
Yeah.
Also, I saw something on your Instagram
I wanted to pull up.
Okay.
Is this due to a breakup response as well?
You dyed your armpit hair blue.
Yeah.
You know, it's just like a little bit of subtle anarchy.
Blue armpits.
Yeah, I was going through a breakup.
I mean, I've created total anarchy.
One boyfriend was just a jerk
and I went and spray painted his car
in middle the night.
No.
Oh yeah.
What color?
I just used black and he called me the next day,
and he's like, "Did you do this?"
And I was like, "No."
(audience laughs)
But guess what?
I did.
(audience laughs)
I'm impressed by you.
That takes a lot to get the spray paint
off of an automobile.
It was the funnest night too.
We like blasted Cypress hill
and did it in the middle of the night.
And I don't know, it just, the whole thing felt really good.
I kind of wanna like spray paint something together.
I kind of wanna have two people break up with us
and see what you and I would do.
We could Thelma and Louise it a little bit.
What do you think?
Yes!
You and me.
(audience applauds)
So tell us about "Severance."
It's a really interesting show.
It's very avant garde, very unique.
It's really popular with people right now.
And is it true that, I wanted to relate to you again,
that you work in a windowless room in it?
'Cause we don't see the daylight here ever.
Yeah, so the office is built in this way
to make you feel a certain way.
And the audience, you know, it takes you on this journey
of yeah, it's windowless, fluorescent lighting.
We were all going a little bonkers wearing masks
and shields, no windows.
And all of a sudden one day,
someone left the outside door open.
We were filming in the Bronx.
And a very friendly chicken walked on to our sound stage,
out of nowhere, starts making itself at home.
It's like sitting on the sound booth,
they're feeding it strawberries.
It goes outside and someone's holding an umbrella.
Oh my god, that's the chicken?
That's the chicken.
I have six chickens, I gotta say, that is a real looker.
(audience laughs)
And so, look, it's sitting on someone's shoulder.
Look, this is-
Oh my god.
I love that someone's holding the umbrella.
We all became so endeared by this chicken
who had just arrived, this random arrival of a chicken
at our sound stage.
And it brought everyone so much joy.
You could see their smile above their masks.
And it was the perfect metaphor for this show
where a lot of bizarre things happen in "Severance."
And I think that the art meets life of it all.
We all kind of came to work to like,
ooh, what kind of weird, odd thing might happen on our set.
And much like the circus, little odd moments
or just to see like the beauty in a moment like that,
to be moved from it, you know?
I mean, I would be so thrilled
if a chicken came through this set.
Actually, my best friend Chicken is here somewhere.
(audience applauds)
Britt Lower, I'm so honored that you've come on our show.
"Severance" is streaming now on Apple TV+,
with new episodes dropping every Friday.
(upbeat bright music)